tomorrow thousands of students are
expected to take to the streets in
Washington and cities around the country
they are demanding an end to school
shootings and other gun violence the so
called March for our lives is organized
by a group of survivors of the school
rampage in parkland Florida just days
after the attack CBS News embedded with
these students as they formed the never
again movement the founding members are
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
junior Cameron Caskey and seniors Emma
Gonzales David hog and Delaney Tarr
these students turned activists show
their tireless fight for a change in gun
laws in America in the CBS News
documentary 39 days it airs tomorrow
night and this morning we have a look at
some never-before-seen video from the
documentary
[Music]
white ni technique spools I couldn't
reach how unless she was farther away
but Nick was right next to me so I
checked his pulse and so did Sam and
then I saw Nick and Helen oh we're dead
[Applause]
do not decrease gun violence we call
we're trying to get people to stop dying
I'm not the same person because like all
of that information has traveled at like
Lightspeed the fact that a hundred
people have tried to follow me in the
past half-hour you're trending ontwitter
year i know we all had these different
things that we were saying and different
things that we were doing that people
were responding to and that was just
kind of a natural push to get us to all
come together and for us to become like
a united force what we have set up right
now we have a website March for our
lives we're going to be doing a march in
March on Washington
where we get students all over the
country are going to be joining us the
adults let us down how many it feels
like it's been weeks it does this all
started at my house we've just been
there I haven't seen her in like 20
minutes the original goals of never
again were to make one Center where we
could all be together and grieve and
demand change in one spot we were trying
to focus on what would get the most
people behind us who can we send out to
which interviews 6:20
everybody's on computers everybody's
making calls everybody's trying to
remember to eat CBS News learned the
suspect Nicholas Cruz purchased at least
seven rifles over the last year
[Music]
it's not trying to destroy the Second
Amendment it's not trying to take away
everyone's gotten something we want an
assault weapons ban we want universal
background checks we want reasonable gun
reform we need to talk about it to
lawmakers and they're not even showing
up to our meeting we knew this is gonna
be hard but we weren't expecting this
but like at thoughtfully hopefully we'll
get to actually meet with someone she
was she was so sympathetic to us and she
really understood us I think I think we
have forgotten why we're serving and you
need to remind us
but we are perfectly willing to take off
the time should have been one school
shooting and we should have fixed it and
I'm pissed I'm like a lawyer now since
she's been shot
murder it's great that the kids are out
there together and they have a voice you
know I feel their pain but if they're
gonna concentrate on gun control I think
they're wasting their time what we need
right now in this country is school
safety perimeter around a school just
like there is at a courthouse the new
norm is gonna be at a school and the
future it's gonna be like going to the
airport press secretary Sarah Sanders
says here at the White House officials
will take the next two weeks to meet
with students educators law enforcement
and governors to discuss what can be
done I've had toast aired mothers and
fathers who have lost their children in
the eye but it's the fact that we're
getting something done here that makes
everything okay it's not really but it
makes everything seem okay I mean
sometimes when I'm falling asleep I
start to remember and it starts to hit
me 17 times
[Music]
you know to remind yourself how young
these children are and how poised they
are and determined they are something
we're going to be following across the
country
tomorrow's a movement it's amazing to
see their stories be reminded of their
power and what's different from this and
other shootings is there's often a lot
of focus on the person who did the act
in this case the focus is on the victims
and the survivors they have a lot of
support they do and you can see the full
documentary 39 days tomorrow night at
8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS